listen aside from your family and your
loved ones and your friends no one
remembers average and ordinary no one
does today I'm going to share with you
10 stories 10 customer service stories
where somebody took it to a whole
different level and today someone like
me is talking about it on a video so
before I get into the episode if you
haven't yet subscribed to the channel
please do so if you got any thoughts
about today's episode comment below let
me get right into it the first story I'm
going to tell you
it's out of this book called the hero
effect by Kevin Brown very simple book
but a great book our home office right
now they're all reading this book
because everybody's working on customer
service on 20/20 so having said that
while I'm reading this book I'm talking
to Mario we're talking about one of the
stories in a book has to do with Disney
it's a story of his son Josh brown who
is autistic
and at seven years old his son finds out
about Disneyland and he falls in love
and falls on about the disney stories at
nine years old he decides to take his
son to Disneyland so they go there they
wake up in the morning they want to go
have some breakfast when they walk in
host this very nice they get to the
table waitress comes terrible attitude
this waitress got to the entire family
cold temperamental disrespect just had
all has no tolerance for customer
service and they're going through all
the other stuff and like this and my son
he'd like to have apple pancakes
you know just blow them off and then
goes off then all of a sudden the
executive chef shows up the executive
chef shows up and says listen Josh what
can I get you and Josh says I like to
have apple pancakes says look I spoke to
your family I kind of know what how you
like it to be made but we don't have it
is it okay if I get you eggs and bacon
and he says yeah sure I'll have that
great baya walks away the executive chef
she walks away they bring the regular
breakfast all good to go they eat they
leave they go home you know like why was
the attitude of the waitress so bad
you're living in the happiest place are
you're working at the happiest place on
earth why do you have this kind of an
attitude they leave kind of messing with
their head a little bit about the
customer service that was given by the
waitress next day they want to eat you
only got one place to go it's this place
they go in they see the hostess very
nice waitress
seize their face walks off again but the
the the the executive-chef sees Josh
Brown and says oh that's aunt Bayer she
shows up she says hey what would you
like to have for breakfast they talked
about it
she knows what he wants he has she has
the apple pancakes they said wait a
minute
I thought you don't have apple pancakes
on your menu she says yes I know you I
don't so how do you have it now
did you guys mad it to your menu no how
did you get it I went to the store and I
bought it on your own time yes I left
work I realize how to make it I came
back I bought the recipe I have it in
the back I like to bring it to you
families like are you kidding me yeah no
problem aunt Belle goes back that's what
the kid Josh calls him goes back cooks
it brings it back to the kid kids like
wait a minute this is how well they eat
the food Kevin the father's blown away
they go back to display spending money
just because of one person baya now
because the waitress three examples host
is nice waitress terrible attitude
executive chef comes and helps on
fast-forward years later baya executive
chef ends up leading 200 employees and
gets promotion after promotion after
promotion why because nobody remembers
average and ordinary right no one does
who you've heard the same no one
remembers normal no one remembers
average and ordinary nobody remembers it
here's a person that took it to another
level let me give you another story it's
the story about lego I'm a lego guy so
I'm a big fan of Lego my kids love Lego
so this kid has all this money that
comes in so that he gets for Christmas
he decides to go and buy the Ninjago
Lego kids for himself and then one day
him and his father are going out the dad
says leave your Lego at the house I say
this to my kids all the time so I
understand what the father's doing
says leave the Lego at the house what
does a kid say Luke says no I want to
take this stuff so he takes the Lego
with them Luca and they go and he ends
up losing it so he comes back that's
that I told you so but he's upset Lucas
disappointed because this wasn't in
Jocko that he bought with all the money
that he saved he decides to write a
letter and send it to Lego and this is
what the letter says hello my
name is Luca Apps and I'm seven years
old with all my money I got for
Christmas I bought the Ninjago kid from
ultrasonic Raider the number is nine
four four nine it is really good my
daddy just took me to Sainsbury's and
told me to leave the people at home but
I took them and I lost jzx at the shop
as it fell out of my coat I'm really
upset I have lost them daddy said to
send you an email to see if you will
send me another one I promise I won't
take him to the shop again if you can
Luca they respond back Lego and this is
what they say he told me to tell you
Luca your father seems to be a very wise
man you must always protect your Ninjago
minifigures like the Dragons protect the
weapons of spin Jitsu since they will
also told me it was ok if I sent you a
new jay and told me it will be okay if I
included something extra for you because
anyone that saves their Christmas money
to buy the ultrasonic Raider must be a
really big Ninjago fan so I hope you
enjoy your Jay minifigure with all his
weapons you will actually have the only
J minifigure that combines three
different Jays into one I'm also going
to send you a bad guy for him to fight
just remember what Sensei Wu said keep
your minifigures protected like the
weapons of Spinjitzu and of course
always listen to your dad can you
imagine that letter comes back so watch
what they just did they spoke kids
language Lucas language seven years old
they protected the data and said always
listen to that and they still allowed
his man imagination take place by
thinking the emails coming from Sensei
Wu imagine what that does to the kid and
imagine what that does to be a father
now how many emails you think they get
every day how many people you can
contact them every day these types of
stories somebody may say well Pat is
there really a currency to it or return
to it I can tell you what then for a
fact somebody may look at this and say
Pat I'm not really sure if there's a way
to monetize this for Lego I can tell you
one thing the person who is doing this
and responding back that person's value
goes up not maybe not the company's
value goes up that person's value goes
up because the customer is always gonna
know how they were treated I'm a given
let me give you another story here the
next one is the famous legendary story
of North strums how this man one day
this
to return tires and people say is this a
myth is this real is this a legend I
don't know if I buy this or not so then
later on they go and verify this with
the president of Nordstrom's okay they
go to Eric Nordstrom and they say did
this story really happen and they say
yes this actually did really happen
what do you mean this really happened
you mean to tell me one day a man comes
in with two tires and says I bought
these tires from here and I need you to
take it back and Nordstrom's employee
took it back I know we have a return
policy but you took back tires you don't
sell tires and the president says it is
true that did happen the stories from
the 70s because at that time we bought
several tire stores in Alaska and we
turned them into Nordstrom's and at the
time former customers who bought the
tires from the building that used to be
a tire shop they brought it in so we
said look since we bought the tire shop
and it used to be a tire shop we'll take
the tires back they took the tires back
and they gave these customers money for
tires like we're not a tire shop that
story has been told since the 70s we're
talking 50 years of marketing for
Nordstrom's just because of customer
service how do you monetize how much
marketing value that has brought how
many books have written about how many
videos have talked about how many
articles have been written about that
that's what you call the power of
customer service you can't put a dollar
to it but the amount of marketing it
brings is absolutely amazing let me give
you another one some basic ones for you
here's a guy that sees an older man
walking out of Wendy's and it decides to
use the umbrella to make sure he goes to
his car without getting wet and he's
using that just the basic employee comes
out to help there's not a story to it
you don't have to do something
significant for people to remember this
is just another example of doing this
here's another picture of an employee
working at Target and you notice this
kid right there that he's got the shirt
and the tie the employee of Target is
helping him look better to go get his
job when he goes to a job interview of
course you're gonna remember a story
like this let me give you another one
one time in Pennsylvania this 89 year
old man is trying to get some food but
it snows them because Pennsylvania snows
in a lot and he wants to go buy food
from Trader Joe's but he can't because
he snowed in so he
his daughter his daughter calls Trader
Joe's Trader Joe's doesn't have a
delivery policy says listen my father's
89 years old I'm sure he's trying to get
some food but he can I just wanted to
call you see if there's anything can do
about this to see if we can get him some
food I know you don't deliver but we'll
pay for it so the lady working at Trader
Joe's says listen don't worry about it
I'm gonna go ahead and deliver whatever
your father wants just give me the list
and don't even worry about having to pay
for it they deliver everything her
father wanted within 30 minutes from
Trader Joe's and the father gets the
food because it was snowed in
again another story where somebody's
going to remember let me give you
another story here this is another story
of somebody who goes to Morton
Steakhouse is on a flight that's the
story of Peter Shankman he's on a flight
he's flying back he sends a tweet saying
you know I arrived at the gate by this
time it'd be great for me to get a steak
you know and I'll and at this time this
airline I'd love to have a steak right
he arrives leaves the gate Morton's
Steakhouse is waiting outside with the
exact steak he ordered and they
delivered it to him and he's like you
gotta be kidding me posts a picture
became the whole frenzy on social media
guess who gets all the love with that
Morton's Steakhouse as well as the
people that are working there again it's
going above and beyond what the other
people are doing Ritz Carlton my CFO
used to be working at risk Carlton for a
long time their customer service at Ritz
Carlton is absolutely impeccable I was
at this ritz-carlton at Rancho Mirage
two nights I was there once last week
came back and I was there just yesterday
and I gotta tell you any time I go to
Ritz Carlton very predictable great
customer service and and I have endless
stories of my CFO that I have to hear
from on how incredible customer service
Ritz Carlton has respect to them here's
a story of a family that goes to Ritz
they stay there the kid leaves his
stuffed giraffe which is the one he goes
to sleep with at the hotel father calls
back saying listen my son left his
stuffed giraffe there and and I really
got to get this if you got a kid that
has a stuff you know animal you know how
it is to them it's very emotional
connection I got to get this
yeah please send us back to me Ritz
Carlton doesn't just send her back to
them Ritz Carlton takes this stuffed
giraffe
they take pictures by the pool they
think
pictures in the spa they take pictures
of this thing they create a small little
booklet they send the kid this stuffed
giraffe back with the book saying while
you was while your giraffe was here
here's some of the experiences in he did
just think about the small little thing
that may cost an additional 20 bucks an
additional 45 minutes of doing that but
the story lasts a lifetime I'll give you
another story here
Amazon always gets a black eye doesn't
matter what it is if Jeff Bezos give us
away ninety five million dollars to an
organization they'll say he didn't give
enough if if Amazon goes out there and
what you don't wants to create jobs I'll
say it's not enough anything Amazon does
it's never enough it's always black and
media today maybe this may be a good
thing for them one time this father buys
a Playstation for his kid and he wants
to get it for this kid for Christmas so
they deliver it but they drop it off at
the front and someone steals it he calls
Amazon saying they saw somebody stole
this PlayStation from front of my
doorstep I was getting it for my kid I
have to get this for my kid he's
pleading he's talking to them he's
trying to convince them that this took
place Amazon finally says listen let us
see what we can do he gets off the phone
it's not thinking Amazon's gonna do
anything next thing you know Amazon
decides to send them then another
PlayStation no costs were shipping and
handling and they deliver to him before
Christmas Day the father starts talking
about it with everybody
this is again a small little thing that
to do Amazon can't afford to do
something like this but the story lasts
a lifetime
and that's Amazon stories that many
times you don't hear about last but not
least Starbucks
there's this lady that works at
Starbucks one of her customers is deaf
he keeps coming in because he's a
regular she feels because she can't
communicate with him she ends up
part-time on the side learning how to
speak sign language just to communicate
with this customer the customer comes
back saying I cannot believe a Starbucks
employee took the time to learn how to
communicate with me in my language
imagine the value of that so again
remember this I'll give you from two
different perspectives one you're
running a business you are the
entrepreneur and you're looking at the
same should I be talking about customer
experience not just customer service
customer experience this is all customer
experience stories I'm sharing with you
should I talk about this should I start
spending more time about this every time
we had we would at one point I would
have an initiative saying listen here's
what I'm
do I want to do giveaways we gave away
6000 $5 Starbucks cards we said we're
gonna give away to charity we walked
into people who were client of ours and
we did a giveaway we walked into five
clients workplaces surprise them and
saying you're going to Disneyland on us
because that's what they want to do for
their kids we would find that their wish
list just to give them that kind of an
experience our employees have the
ability to talk to one of our agents of
our clients and say hey I notice this
birthday's coming up or that things
coming up I have a budget to send them a
gift they have the budget to send them a
gift if they want to because these small
little markers are the differentiators
because between somebody who wins
loyalty with their customer and somebody
doesn't so if you're the entrepreneur
running a business today remember this
forty years ago thirty years ago even
fifteen years ago you could get away
with somebody saying bad things about
you you can't today today everybody has
Yelp all these other things that they
can go say stuff about you right when it
comes down to customer service it is
more important today to give an
incredible customer experience to your
customers than ever before and let me
give you the other side you may be
saying Pat I'm not and I'm not an
entrepreneur I work for a company why
should I go above and beyond I'm on a
flight yesterday from American Airlines
back from Palm Springs right I walk in
the lady is standing in front of me I'm
standing for 45 seconds she's looking at
me doesn't say how are you not one time
she's looking at me
not saying how are you one time okay the
employee behind her it's like hi how are
you how you doing I take my jacket I
said can I get my jacket not right now
after we order the drinks he says I'll
take the jacket I'll hang it up hey I'm
gonna same company to different
employees so who gets bad reputation
there's American Airlines news here no
because the American Airlines has
somebody that's doing the right thing
she her brand takes a hit because watch
this I have an employee that works for
me her name is Alexis moody okay Alexis
moody started helping me 15 years ago
and I was paying her $400 a month that's
all I could afford to pay her because at
that time she was giving me a few hours
a week to help okay $400 man I was 25
years old so 16 years ago okay and she's
helping me she was a single mother at
the time and she was doing this on the
side to help me out then all of a sudden
I'm working with her and I start getting
stories did you know Alexis did this did
you know Alexis did that did you know
Alexis did this one you do know Alexis
did that for me
and she's not telling people to tell me
this story all these stories are coming
back my said she did that yeah she did
this yeah huh maybe I got a locker in
then I locked her in and I locked her
and Alexis what do you need what do you
want then I send her to the spa
then I took care of her then we traveled
all over to I send her places what do
you want to do everything with Alexis
because it's so hard to find a person
like Alexis yes what fast forward today
Alexis drives a nice 7 Series BMW she's
got two kids she's got a nice place over
here she owns a piece of the company and
she officially got promoted to director
why why because her company
Alexis Moody incorporated the value went
up because of what she does when
nobody's watching
and CEOs entrepreneurs come say I don't
notice what she does say I'm assured
that doesn't take care of her say I'm a
boss that doesn't take care of her you
don't think the marketplace well you
don't think that thousands of people
she's treated royally are gonna say Pat
doesn't want to take care of I'll hire
her you don't think you're watching this
right now you're gonna go search it to
find out who she is her service isn't
that good and she deserves this much
love for what she does again company pay
attention to it more important than ever
today as an employee salesperson within
a company pay attention to because
increases your value of what you do
become better person when it comes on to
customer experience having said that
there's two other videos I want you to
watch if the topic of customer service
customer experience is important too I
got two of them one of the videos I want
you to watch has been shown at Microsoft
Google Stanford because I get these
messages about this video it's titled
customer service vs. customer experience
it's a very simple video explaining how
to do this and the other one is 19
mistakes to avoid when it comes on to
customer service I do one of these
videos both of them have to do is top
the topic click on them to watch and
again if you haven't subscribed to the
channel please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye bye
you
[Music]